la siguiente figura muestra la gráfica
de f prima es decir la derivada de la
función f que es dos veces derivable en
el intervalo menos 34 entonces tenemos
un intervalo cerrado la gráfica de f
prima tiene tangentes horizontales en x
igual a menos uno en ex igual a 1 y en x
igual a 3 entonces observamos que aquí
en x igual a menos 1
vamos a tener una tangente horizontal se
vería más o menos así en x igual a 1
también tenemos otra tangente horizontal
que se va a ver así y también pasa lo
mismo en x igual a 3 tenemos otra
tangente horizontal y después dice el
área de la región encerrada por el eje x
y la gráfica f prima en los intervalos
menos 21 y 1.4 es de 9 y de 12
respectivamente ok entonces si nos
fijamos en la región encerrada por el
intervalo menos 21
toda esta tiene un área de 9 es justo lo
que dice tiene una área de 9 entonces
vamos a escribirlo esté aquí tiene un
área de 9 y también nos dicen que la
región encerrada por el intervalo 1 a 4
por el intervalo 14 toda esta región
tiene un área de 12 así que lo voy a
escribir también aquí tenemos un área de
12 muy bien inciso a encuentra todas las
coordenadas x en donde f
tengo un máximo relativo justifica tu
respuesta y observando que dice
encuentra todas las coordenadas x en
donde f tenga un máximo relativo ojos
seguramente va a estar muy tentado a
decir oh mira aquí tengo un máximo
relativo y que acabamos pero ten cuidado
porque esta no es la gráfica de f
esta es la gráfica de ese prima de x
entonces hay que pensar un poco este
problema porque no tenemos la gráfica de
f dada de una manera explícita
así que pensemos un poco que tiene que
pasar para que f tengo el máximo
relativo bien primero si no estás
familiarizado con cómo se ve un máximo
relativo se va a ver más o menos así
como un pequeño chip o está bueno
también se podría ver algo así pero esta
no es una función derivable en este
intervalo así que seguramente no se ve
así lo que buscamos entonces qué sabemos
de estos máximos relativos bueno pues si
tenemos aquí a nuestro máximo relativo
lo voy a poner justo aquí entonces lo
primero que sabemos es que los valores
cercanos a esta x a este máximo relativo
por la izquierda tienen una pendiente
positiva y tienen una pendiente positiva
porque la función está creciendo
conforme nos acercamos a este valor
así que observa que todos
estos de aquí tienen una pendiente
positiva entonces déjame escribirlo efe
está creciendo
está
creciendo
y eso quiere decir que entonces la
primera derivada de x va a tener que ser
más grande que 0 tiene que ser positiva
y después de pasar este punto máximo
después de pasar este punto máximo que
pasa con todos estos puntos aquí bueno
pues si observas la función aquí está
decreciendo y si está decreciendo eso
quiere decir que la pendiente de la
recta tangente de cada uno de estos
puntos es negativa va hacia abajo
entonces también lo voy a escribir en
este caso
efe ésta
decreciendo entonces la primera derivada
de x es menor que cero y observa eso es
lo que pasa justo aquí en este máximo
relativo tenemos un valor de x donde la
derivada cambia de ser mayor que cero de
ser mayor que cero a ser menor que cero
entonces vamos a escribir eso que es muy
importante
efe tiene un máximo relativo
si pasa aquí bueno si pasa que la
derivada ojo estamos hablando aquí de la
derivada cambia de positiva a negativa
de positiva a negativa positiva a
negativa y bueno entonces ahora nos
podemos fijar en la gráfica de acá
arriba del nuevo podemos regresar aquí y
ver en donde pasa esto como esta es la
gráfica de f prima de x vamos a fijarnos
en donde f prima cambia de ser positiva
a ser negativa y si observas va a pasar
justo aquí observa aquí tenemos la
función positiva positiva positiva
positiva positiva cruzamos este punto y
nos convertimos en negativa negativa
negativa observa puedes ver que aquí la
función f prima es mayor que 0 en todo
esto
efe prima es mayor que 0 justo aquí y
eso quiere decir que f está creciendo
pasamos a esto
punto de aquí pasamos en este punto de
aquí y después de esto observa qué efe
prima es negativa aquí ya tenemos a efe
prima negativa observa la entonces en
este valor de x igual a menos 2
efe lina cambia de positiva negativa
entonces ya podemos asegurar que f ojo
no es de prima f está creciendo en ese
intervalo porque f prima es positiva
después llegamos a este valor de menos 2
y pasando este valor de menos 2
efe está decreciendo aquí porque f prima
es negativa entonces ahora sí ya podemos
concluir podemos decir que esto de aquí
esto de aquí pasa esto de aquí pasa esto
pasa
en donde bueno en x igual a menos 2 y
observa es el único punto en donde pasa
eso así que esa es la respuesta del
inciso a